let's take the courtroom scene in a few
good men and break it down by beaks and
what are some of the parts that make it
so memorable a five from the infamous
line from Jessup to the end sure
well it depends if you're talking about
the whole courtroom the whole trial
because the trial actually begins at the
midpoint for sure and then it ends at
the climax really and cares all the way
to the end of the movie so through the
whole trial it's been using a number of
sort of key structural devices one is
you want to you want to move back and
forth between the hero being in control
and the opposition being in control so
you want the audience to be kept a
little bit off balance at times we think
okay now that Cathy really is winning
but then then the Kevin Bacon character
I forget his name the prosecuting
attorney he comes back oh no now he's
winning oh no now he's winning and now
he's winning so you don't want it to
just be bad Dada Dada Dada Dada and then
good good good good good it's got to go
back and forth back and forth so there's
sort of peaks and valleys to the
emotional experience of that overall
sequence the next thing you want to do
is it also combines a couple of key
structural devices one is anticipation
and one is surprise anticipation means
we're trying to figure out what's going
to happen next and you can increase that
device or you can strengthen that tool
if you use what I refer to as superior
position so let your audience know
something that some of the characters
don't know for example we know that
Kaffee is going to try and going to call
Jessup and try and get him to admit what
he did but nobody else knows so we're
anticipating what's going to happen when
Jessup gets up there how is he going to
go about doing that
so that's actually curiosity as well as
anticipation okay we anticipate on that
what's going to happen when he calls up
the Airmen that we're in the flight
tower for this non-existent flight and
calls them up to testify so we're
curious about
batar we're anticipating what's that
going to be like and and we're
anticipating what's he going to do now
that Murchison or whatever his name is
is committed suicide so a lot of it is
what's going to happen now what's going
to happen next what's going to happen
next but sometimes the audience doesn't
want to try and predict what's going to
happen next they want to be totally
surprised so the surprise is one
surprises when we learn later that those
two guys from the tower didn't know
anything about the flight they were just
a red herring they were just to make
make Jessup believe that he had evidence
that he didn't have we weren't given
that information at a time we in the
audience so that created a twist that
created surprise so sometimes you want
to lead your audience toward
anticipating and expecting something
sometimes you want to turn the tables on
them or jump out and go boo or do
something that's completely unexpected
the next thing that makes that work is
the obstacles just like through the
movie are getting bigger and bigger so
the testimony becomes harder and harder
harder to get to the truth and finally
comes Jessup who we know is going to be
the most difficult thing to overcome
I mean just imagine the movie if Jessup
was the first witness and then after
that we had Cuba Gooding jr. is one of
the one of the small parts in this movie
it's ridiculous to anticipate because
instinctively we all know you've got to
let's save the biggest and the best for
last and then even in that final
confrontation where Jessup's on the
stand it's like okay we we have some
more superior position and that is we
know that he's terrified of doing this
and then if he fails he's going to get
court-martialed
now the other characters may realize
that but they're not they aren't aware
of how frightened Cathy is and they
don't know what he has up his sleeve
like we in some ways do we know he's
going to use the the shirts that he saw
in his closet but we don't know how so
again it's just this this combination of
surprise anticipation curiosity conflict
peak moments small moments and then one
last thing and that is if you just look
at the arc of Jessup's testimony you
will see that it
starts out everything Kathy's trying to
get him to say doesn't really get very
far yeah he's turning the phone logs and
guys Joanie me didn't pack and there are
questions but he's but Jessup is just
very confident he says is this all you
got you know footlocker's and phone
calls you know I hope you got something
more than that these people are they're
on trial for their lives and he's so
sure of himself but then as soon as he
asks him why two commands why the two
orders if he was so safe because the
first order why did he have to be sent
away from the base and then we see the
turn and now we see that everything is
going to shift and where it seemed like
Kathy was going down and Jessup was good
was rising now it shifts and now Kathy
is in control until finally Jessup sort
of you know ruins his own future by
confessing that he he and he of course
did order order the Code Red
it's just all those things in such a
wonderful combination that's really hard
to pick it apart that way because it
still takes away the magic of it because
when you see it you just get so caught
up in it
you